you wanna know a little pilot secret
like everyone here hi my name is Fox
machete customized a captain for a major
US commercial airline she's also a
former avionics engineering officer for
the Pakistan Air Force today I'll be
breaking down clips from movies and TV
about flying overweight take off
American made No Mas no mas mas there's
plenty of room guys it ain't about room
alright it's about weight just because
there's empty room that you can see in
the aircraft does not mean you can fill
it up all the way to the brain no mas an
aircraft every time before it flights is
required to be checked for performance
and weight and balance you calculate a
center of gravity for that particular
flight and you calculate how much weight
you can carry in what part of the
aircraft the aircraft has to be within a
certain operating envelope for it to
conduct the entire flight safely oh whoa
where the hell you think you're going
big fella either I fly the big fella or
I fly a product Tom Cruise was correct
in kick kicking the guy out he's
probably also flying the aircraft
further away if so he's carrying as much
fuel as he can maybe even more to
conduct a long flight
the depiction of an overweight takeoff
they're doing is pretty much on point
he tries to lift off and the stall
warning horn goes off that stall warning
horn is an indication that a stall is
about to occur he does not rush the
take-off which is exactly what you
should have done when a stall occurs
there's just not enough air flow and the
way basically quits flying
[Music]
he wants to get rid of the drag of the
aircraft so he lifts their landing gear
up up until that point I was with it but
then he's still stalling which means he
still doesn't have enough lift the
aircraft's still not ready to fly you're
forcing it to take off and then now
you're hitting trees and you keep flying
not very realistic I do tend to leap
before I look sky law 30 rock Stuart
21:18 that guy excuse me mr. sweat pants
we're gonna need to check that bag and
that is sky law no there's no such thing
as a sky law per se or codes that we use
with flight attendants as a matter of
fact most of the times when we get on an
aircraft to fly it we're meeting the pro
for the first time in our lives
excuse me young lady are you old enough
to be travelling along so Matt Damon in
this scene is acting all like has all
this authority as captain of the
aircraft is impressing Tina Fey Roger
that
and is wearing the wrong hat he's the
Kazon of the aircraft he is wearing a
copilot hat you want to know a little
pilot secret besides the fact that we
get a discount in sunglasses pilots get
discounts at a lot of places so glass
Hut at the airport is actually why no
thumb but pilots get pretty much
discounted all the retail outlets and
food stores restaurants at the airport
didn't miss a half an hour over an hour
ago
so the 30-minute rule you both start to
get a little antsy back there yeah it's
gonna be about another half hour I wish
I could say it never existed however I
can now say with a lot of confidence and
faith looking into your eye that we're
not doing it anymore the half-hour thing
it's a trick it's enough time so that
people know they're gonna have to wait
but it doesn't upset them and can you
tell me when we might be in the air
captain sure in about a half an hour so
when I
as a captain give out any information it
is pretty much exactly what I know Oh
folks half an hour means forever Oh
Bert's right celli well you know the
only day to get out of it why what's
that okay the flight attendants
complaining about how awful the quarry
is is very accurate the nickname for
LaGuardia in the industry is 'la garbage
a lot of reasons that LaGuardia is hated
are this the similar reasons why most
passengers don't like it either it's an
airport that's overgrown its capacity a
little bit of weather causes extensive
delays once you've landed the taxi times
could be up a few hours I love the board
yet my favorite airport in the whole
wide world there's LaGuardia very far by
2,000 pounds per Barnes we got 19,000
people the pilot and co-pilot when
they're taking the runway that
conversation that's happening it's not
conversation it's not talking it's pure
business
it's called a thorough flight deck
pilots cannot talk to each other have
any conversation that's not about the
particular flight they're flying until
the aircraft is above 10,000 feet it may
seem like why is there a need for two
people to say the same thing
the first officer is the pilot flying
calls out 19,000 pounds required 21.8 on
board the captain verifies it it's
called a takeoff fuel or minimum
take-off fuel for that matter
birds withstand a certain limit or
number of bird strikes there's no hard
fast limit for it but it's not like the
engine just one small bird will bring
the airplane down get out the qrh both
engines curate just a quick reference
handbook any abnormal situation is
handled by the qrh it's like a cookbook
it is a step by step by step what tip
Mayday Mayday Mayday this is cactus 1549
once an aircraft says Mayday he owns
everything every help is available to
him Teterboro tower I need a runway
cactus 1549 needs to go to the airport
right now Newark Tower what have you got
they're giving him every option they
stopped the airspace they give him every
airport every one way that's available
to him but I'll tell you everything they
know that will help you make a good
decision cactus 1549 to right to meet
you you can land runway 1-0 if you look
at this plate everything that has
happened in it was very good with
superior airmanship as we call it and
that's why it led to the result that it
did they followed all the right steps
that should have been followed mission
start I'm starting anything new and you
see the result I came out of it
emergency landing keine air we got a
landing on the Las Vegas Strip bad idea
out of all the places in Las Vegas what
they could have picked Strip was the
worst
they weren't insane being a pilot is not
just physically flying the aircraft a
lot of it is the decision-making the
most biggest airport it's just past the
strip can you see it so right at this
spot where they are don't pretty much
wind up with McCarran Airport it's right
there bad you can make it so if they're
facing the West in that shot McCarran
Airport has two runways runway one nine
left and one ninth ray which is just to
their left all the how to do is make a
left turn and they had a straight shot
to that runway
as soon as they hit that guitar of the
High Rock Cafe they'll lose half their
wing they actually lose an aileron
which is a control surface that controls
the roll movement of an aircraft the
roll movement with the this movement of
the aircraft if they lose the left
aileron on the left part of the wing
that should be any of that plate the
airplane should not be able to maintain
level play after that it should go into
a roll right away landing on the Las
Vegas Strip was the worst of the ideas
eyelet can make oh sure air traffic
control Saturday night line
all right no there's no a Tech Talk for
molecules back man I know you're coming
order or ple volley up there but I'm
gonna have you do the escape faster than
a weapon gets a hard-on okay
English is English Bank comes with all
kinds of accents from all over the world
one of the harder ones is actually
Scottish ships hi I'm so sorry your
accent is very thick you can also ask
them to repeat but there's only so many
times you can ask them to repeat before
annoying them and it they can also be
busy so it's not like you can just like
ask for them to repeat everything how
about we show fear that when they didn't
Agron tell me if you can rest your
goggles upon or contortion plane station
the instructions are standardized I'm
expecting a certain type of instruction
who's about to come every instruction
usually contains a heading altitude or a
speed I have an idea what's coming back
there was active legit aviation
instructions coming I probably would
have been able to understand it I should
be able to understand it don't do
anything great what so I am speaking
with a perspective of being an American
person going into other countries but I
have heard a lot of complaints from
foreign pilots that when they come to
New York especially Kennedy they have
the hardest time with air traffic
control for two reasons one its American
English second New Yorkers speak really
fast and third JFK or New York airspace
is one of the most complicated airspace
systems in the world they're dealing
with a lot of traffic and the operation
is very fast so all that is it's
difficult to understand what the flight
control plate
[Applause]
[Music]
as soon as the aircraft goes in a
nosedive the aircraft starts screaming
whoa whoop pull up that doesn't happen
at high altitudes that is a system and
aircraft that stops it from impact when
it is close to ground or close to
structures or a close to terrain and
30,000 feet the aircraft does not say
pull up it's just adding drama and chaos
to the scene you need to dump the fuel
don't weigh fuel dump is only on very
large airplanes that carry fuel for
hours and hours and hours
domestic airplanes that have a range of
four or five hours don't have fuel dumps
on them it's not like a light switch on
and off you turn the fuel dump on and
off aside the entire aircraft is out of
fuel it takes high pilots are there to
flight the aircraft they can reach every
switch and button from where they're
sitting at their station buckled in
they don't need Margaret to come for
that manual control which does not even
exist on that aircraft this movie was
made post 9/11 in the United States post
9/11 flight that door is not open the
flight attendant is not going in and out
just like it's a walk in the park
maintain altitude but oil pressure
failure
let's talk about that fire the first
saucer in a very scary way oh my god we
have like the right engine on fire so he
what goes ahead and pulls that one lever
that's lit up already once you pulled
that handle you shut that engine off
then a few seconds later the first
officer once again all freaking out says
we just lost an engine of course you
lost an engine you just suck them up
there should be no power there should be
no electricity on the airplane
everything should go dark they shouldn't
be able to have any radio communication
the very next thing is he asked Margaret
you just shut those engines off what are
you adding power to so this aircraft has
a problem that it is in an uncontrolled
nosedive situation the captain decides
to fly the aircraft and burn it so he
can stop losing that altitude that
they're losing extra fast that makes
sense
[Music]
they go inverted the Obrecht they arrest
the rate of descent by themselves time
at all the spine but no when they come
out of that inverted lathe or back level
again how did the aircraft not go back
into a nosedive right away they have not
fixed the problem
all that engine shutting down in the
fire shutting down and all the drama
that just happened has not corrected the
problem the problem still exists this is
a very peculiar situation not something
that you train for every day video game
but it has to have rhyme or reason and
logic behind doing what you're doing
which does not exist in this gunfight
non-stop
[Applause]
so there's one gunshot fired a bullet
goes through the window of the aircraft
there's wind like there's a hurricane
inside the cabin one small bullet hole
will not make so much wind and debris
flying all over the the cabin
[Music]
the bullet hole was not enough to cause
a rapid decompression and the cabin but
the loss of the window did there's rapid
decompression and the oxygen masks come
down which is a correct picture but how
did the window just decide to fly out
there's no good reasoning behind that
those panels are lifting up when the
aircraft is going down or actually sweet
breaks he is trying to get the airplane
down fast in the shortest amount of time
the manoeuvre they're showing is not
coherent with that weight loss situation
to get the aircraft weightless you would
actually do the opposite you climb the
aircraft when you reach the top of the
climb when you push back down is when
you get weightless commercial airliners
are not designed to be flown in a
weightless situation none of that should
not happen right I fail to unruly
passenger meet the parents no we still
cannot say the word bomb there are
certain trigger words that get attention
and bomb is one of them ba ba ba ba ba
ba BOM ba ba ba ba ba ba ba in this
particular scene the flight attendant
was very very nice and she let this go
much further than it would it would have
in real life take a little sticks out of
your head clean out your ears and maybe
you would see that I'm a person who has
feelings and all I have to do is do what
I want to do and all I want to do is
hold on to my bag and not listen to you
we all get someone on the aircraft
something very similar to this saying oh
I swear my back fit it will fit it
always fits it been in the previous
flight the only way that I would ever
let go of my bag would be if you came
over here right now and tried to pry it
from my dead lifeless fingers not
everybody is there to get you was
against you this happens more often than
people can fake pilot schedules la
today's what's your problem man problem
right now is I'm talking to an overrated
hack whose stick work is pedestrian so
basically what he's trying to say that
is a big insult for a pilot but I was
never serious about taking over this
godforsaken flight I mean come on Dave
look at me I fly international there is
some unwritten prestige involved the
pilots who come off an international
flight somehow they have to just say hey
I'm just coming from London I just
landed from Paris I have done that and I
see others day back so it's there I fly
Internet
okay stop calling it international Steve
let's call it what it is it's Canada
he's actually right for the purposes of
airline International Planet schedules
Canada is not considered an
international destination nieghbors
Mexico what counts they have their own
money that doesn't even fit in wallet
engine fire Air Force One
[Music]
so the Air Force when is intercepted by
MiG's Megas a Russian fighter jet
if there's an aircraft with more than
one engine losing an engine is not a
huge big emergency that is going to make
you fall out of the sky wait a fourth I
he says what we're turning to the right
very typical response in an engine
failure
there is less thrust on the right side
than the website naturally the aircraft
will rotate towards the right which is
happening in this case Harrison Ford's
first remark is oh should I pull number
one engine back which is a good good
idea I like for someone who's not a
pilot however we don't take away the
power that we already have on an engine
or the thrust that's being produced
thank you
how we compensate for it is by the user
rudder rudder is a flight control
surface that controls this motion of the
aircraft how rack the nose going towards
the right side you would apply it left
rudder once you've lost an engine for
the entire duration of the plate you'll
have to hold that rudder in to keep the
nose like this as soon as you release
the pressure on your leg or you feel
like that's tired the airplane will turn
back to work so right again you have to
put it off the trim is just relieving
the pressure the pilot has on the rudder
holding it in it's like riding a bike i
wanna diei my american-made
the DEA was using these fancy new Jets
that we couldn't outrun Tom Cruise's in
a smaller aircraft which consumes or
burns less gas as opposed to the fancy
jet that the DEA is flying they could go
fast in again we could go slow
for a long time so he forces them to
calm down at a lower altitude fly slower
burn more gas aircrafts do burn more gas
on their lower and slower as opposed to
flying higher and faster and that is why
all the commercial flights are flown
around 30,000 some feet no you don't
wait that long if you're waiting for the
earth masses tell you low fuel you're
way behind the aircraft to begin with so
bingo fuel is where you would not
continue what you're doing and just go
and land the aircraft to bring it back
on the ground maximum altitude the crap
[Music]
nealy
you have control I have control so let's
talk about how Prince Phillip takes
control of the aircraft from the pilot
who's flying it who's also a trained
pilot it was done very professionally
you have control I have control it's
visually and verbally verified it's not
like I'll fly a little bit you fly a
little bit to see this aircraft is
45,000 feet the service ceiling in the
air practice is fixed decadent number
published in the aircraft manuals the
absolute ceiling of the aircraft as a
variable number depends on the
temperature of that given day the weight
of the aircraft and other environmental
factors the conditions are favorable the
aircraft can climb from the service
ceiling to the absolutely do not do this
at home
it is not a practice that's common is it
doable yes and that's exactly what
Prince Philip is saying in the steam the
difference between us how fast the
airplane can go and how slow the
airplane can go becomes very little at
that high altitude which we in aviation
terms called a cop in corner but
currently the very image of what this
aircrafts can do exactly what the pilot
in that scene so we're operating this
aircraft to the very limit right now
beautiful if you have ever thought about
flying if you've ever looked up in the
sky I've seen an airplane and think I
wish I'd be there the only one
recommendation I can give you is do it
the feeling that you have when you're
soaring above the clouds that is a
feeling that is indescribable
[Music]